hello thanks for tuning in my name is
jose
and i'm a software engineer in the azure
sdk team at microsoft
i'm sure some of you have worked with
rest api before
and notice how the editors provide
little to no help
when discovering which resources are
available for you to work with
or even when building up your request
payload
in this talk we're going to see how we
can use typescript
to build a client that will help our
rest api users
with suggesting which resources they can
use
which operations they can execute on
those resources they have selected
and also we will help them build the
request payload
before jumping into the code let's take
a look at the sample res
api call
this is a simple call to our imaginary
book catalog service
that we will be using throughout the
talk
the first part is a method which
describes the operation to be executed
on a resource
following is a resource which is
composed of a base url
that remains constant for the service
and a path
which identifies the resource then
we have the payload which is the data
sent to the service
in this case we're sending a request to
add a book to our catalog
on the right we have an image with the
structure of the service we're going to
be writing our client for
it has two resources the first one
supports
get post and put methods
our second resource takes a book id as a
path parameter
and supports get and delete methods
you can find the code from this doc on
this url
and now let's get started we're going to
start by creating a simple factory
function
that takes the base url
we're going to call it the books client
for now let's put it that it will return
the void
i need to take a base url
which is going to be string
all right so we have the books client
and our users will create a books claim
by calling this faction
factory method because client apollo's
books client and the books client will
take a base url let's use
localhost
now we need our client to have a pad
function
that takes the pad that we're going to
be using on the rest api
for that we need to change the return
type that we set this void
to have the shape that we want so we
want to have
an object that has a property named path
and this property is going to be a
function
let's let's put void as a return type
for as a placeholder but this function
needs to take
a string so let's do
pad of type string
so now our client has the pad function
and it takes string if we don't pass a
string then we get an error
now we need that our path function only
accepts the paths that are
available in the rest api right now it
accepts
any string so for that let's start with
moving the pad function definition type
to its own type
let's do export type
pad and we're going to have the same
thing as we have
here and this is the type
pad
so now we need to limit the path it
cannot be the whole string
so for that we can create an interface
that defines the shape of our rest api
where the keys are the paths that are
that are accepted and then the values
are more details about the service so
let's start
with the interface
we're going to call it the book library
and our keys are going to be our pads so
we have one pad that is
slash book
and slash book slash
book id
we want the pad type to be one of the
keys of the book library interface
we can set the type of path to key off
book library so now we get an error
because the empty string is not a key
of the book library interface
and if you start writing
then you will get suggestions about the
pads that you can choose
now we need to be able to detect if the
pad
has a pad parameter then it should be
filled in
for that we can use typescript template
literal types
so let's start by creating a helper type
that will help us detect
if the string that we are passing
has at least one path parameter
so let's create a type type and we're
going to call it path
parameter since we're going to be
working on a string
we're going to call it a t-pad
and it's going to be just a string so we
can say extends
string okay so now for detecting
uh if t pad has any parameters
we can we can start by saying t path so
this is the
the check that we're going to be doing
so t pad extends
and now we need to uh do our template
here
and then if it matches our template
we're going to say that it's going to be
true
otherwise it's going to be false okay
now let's define our template so we can
say that
our parameters are surrounded by
curly braces and then we have a
head that is anything that precedes the
template
i mean the the parameter and then a tail
that is everything that succeeds
the the parameter so in this case
the head is going to be book
the parameter is going to be book id and
then the tail
is going to be an empty string if we had
something different like
a bar here for example then
the head would be book then the
parameter again would be book id
and the tail would be slash bar so with
this we can start building our
parameters
so we will we can say that first we'll
have the head
we can use the infer keyword
for type script that will look at the
the string that we pass
and then it will infer the part uh the
head
so we say head and then after the head
we're gonna have
a slash and we're gonna have curly
braces and whatever is inside
curly braces is going to be our
parameter so we can again say
infer the parameter
parameter and just after the parameter
we're going to have
the tail so again let jabba's
typescript infer the tail
okay so now we have our template
so this will match perfectly so book
bokeh the bar and and bar
so let's create a test type for this
to cost full of
type add parameter and then
this guy will take
book so let's say if book
let's see if book matches so it's false
it doesn't match because
book doesn't have a pad parameter but
what if we
add bokeh theme
all right is it true cool and then if we
have something in the tail
true again okay so this is looking good
so we're able now to detect if there's
at least one parameter
now we need to use this to make it to
have required parameters on our path
function right so how do we do that
so we can use tuple types
to do that so for example instead of
returning a true we can say we're going
to return
a tuple with a string parameter
we're going to have a string parameter
because we we know that we found the
parameter
so the list of required parameters for
for
for the path function is gonna be at
least this
uh single string otherwise if we didn't
find
any any parameters then we'll say
there are no parameters so we can return
an empty tuple
so let's try to use these integrate
these into the
into the path function so right now we
have the pad
is type of the keys of the book library
and now we say that you can have a pad
parameter
and this will be of type pad parameter
okay but pad parameter needs to be
working on a string and we would like
pad parameter to be working on the path
that we're
passing the exact path that was used as
the first parameter
so for that i think we can we can just
lift this up
and put it as a generic of the pad
or maybe just as generic of the function
so you can say
that we're going to be taking a t-pad
and the t-pad is extending extends
so it has to be one of the keys of book
library
and now let me format it okay
so okay so we have this generic
definition here
so t-pad is going to be any of the keys
of book library
so now we can change the pad
type to just be a d-pad which is
basically the same that we had
and now the pad parameters are going to
be
the helper tab that we just created and
it's going to be working on t-pad
cool
nice so let's see what pad looks like
okay
so since book doesn't match
the template that we defined then it's
saying that
it needs a pad parameter of an empty
tuple
which is uh
this this means it doesn't have any
parameters but we're still requiring the
parameters
so what we can do is we can just do the
spread
on on the pad parameters because we know
that this type is going to be
in the form of a tuple but we want
we want the the pad parameters to be
just positional parameters
after the after the path so
we can say that the path parameter and
we're going to spread it
it's going to be a rest parameter so now
you see the the type of the path
function when it has book then we don't
have any parameters
but if we were doing the
one that has a parameter then it's
complaining now because we're not
passing a path parameter
you see here we get a not a very nice
name
we can just name it pat parameter
because tuples
allowed you in allow you to have a label
so you could do pad parameter
yep so now it will be pat parameter
fortunately type step group doesn't
support yet
dynamic labels so i will need to just
skip
predefined label for for for the tuple
so okay so now it's complaining about
not having the the path parameter so we
can pass any path parameter and you will
be happy now our pad parameter helper
type still
has a problem and the problem is that
it's only able
to identify one
path parameter for example if you
if you had another
pad parameter here let's say bar id
then pad parameter will still just
detect the single path parameter
so in order to fix this we can
we can actually recursively call our pad
parameter
helper type to identify the rest of the
strings so
so far whenever we have already
identified a pad parameter
we have looked into this part of the
template the head and the parameter
but then we still need to look at the
tail
so what we can do is we can say
that if you find a parameter then the
parameter is going to be
looking at the tail so we will do pad
parameter
that parameter on
the tail
and since since this again returns
a tuple then we can just spread parents
and now
our helper type is finding both of the
parameters
and if you could keep adding parameters
it will keep detecting them once we set
the path
we need to expose methods for the pairs
that are supported by the rest api
so for example book should support get
post input
while book on book id should support get
and delete
so let's add some placeholder function
definitions on our
interface for each of the paths
now that we have the placeholders for
each of the functions
we can start using this interface in
order to set the right return type for
the pad
function so
for doing that we can replace the void
placeholder that we had
when we're working with interfaces we
can access the content of each of the
keys
so for example we could do book library
on one of the two keys that it has
defined
when you set the key this will be
whatever is defined inside
however we don't want to have it hard
coded this way
we would like to be using whatever path
has been passed to the
to the function and since we're using a
generic d-pad
then we can work with that so instead of
passing in
and string we can just use the t-pad
that is being used
to use t-pad here with this
working on this pad we should get delete
and post
delete and post and if we set
the slash book pad which doesn't require
any parameters we should get
a post to put in the get methods
post get input methods now we need to
set real return types we have set
placeholder voids here
but we need to use real types for for
the
operations that we're executing so for
that i have already created
a few definitions for response types
so let's start looking at the general
response type that has
a status code which is a required
property because
any response will have status code which
is string
then we have an optional body
property this is unknown on the general
response because
this is very specific for the for each
request that we're going to be sending
and then we have the headers which is
basically a key value pair of strings
and an unknown type
for the value then
we have an error response this is any
response that is
returned by the service will have a
status code we know beforehand that our
service may return the 400 for
invalid input 404 when the resource is
not found
or 500 or there was an internal service
error
when the service returns an error you
will have
in the body we will have an error code
and a message about the error
and then we have some types for each of
the specific
requests that we have so for example
when we send a post request to the to
the slash book pad
then i will get a 200
if it's successful and the two sorry
200 201 and the 201 doesn't have a body
so we're going to say that the body in
this case is optional
but um it's going to be a never type so
what you should never expect to have a
body
then we have the list books 200 response
which is the success response when you
call get on the slash books
pad so the status is 200
and you will get a body and the body is
going to be an array of books
now that we have our types defined then
we can start using them
in our book library definition so
let's start filling it out since we're
calling a service
we're going to be getting promises so
let's start with promise
and then slash book get
will get a list books 200 response
or it will get an error response in case
um there was an error the post
will also have a premise
of add book to one response
or an error response put
promise of update
201 response or
the error response
then this get with book id
will give you a promise
of get
book 200 response or an error response
and then the delete will give you
promise with delete
201 response or an error response
now we can see that our delete function
returns a delete book to a one response
or an error response let's assign this
to a variable so that we can explore
the shapes of the results
so let's see what result has result okay
so it has a catch and then because uh
because
the operations return a promise so we
can wait
once we wait we should be able to see
what's in there
so it has a the general structure body
headers and status here we see status we
see
that it can have 201 or any of the
errors
error status codes if we explore the
body
then it will tell us that it can be
either an error body or an undefined
that's because at this point we didn't
know
what kind of response we got we can be
getting a 201 or we can be getting any
other
error response so if we go back to
responses
you will see that we're defining our
status codes for each of the
specific responses as string literal
unions
and this will help our editor tools to
be able
to to narrow down the types
so for example here if we were to say
that
we wanted to throw an error on a
non-successful
result we can say if result
dot status is not equals to 201 which is
our success
then we will throw and we'll draw the
result
body which has the error
properties through control flow analysis
typescript is able to infer that inside
this
block the result is a
narrow response and also since the rest
of the code is not going to be executed
it's able to infer that the result is
going to be the success result so let's
use the
get method the get method
success is at 200 so let's update this
so
outside of here we should be able to see
that the body is a book
so calling result that body
body has a shape of a book and it has
all the properties
from the book author scholar id
publisher and title
the last step is to add the input
parameters to our
functions for that i have already
defined a few types for the input
parameters and also for the book
our book has an id a title a list of
authors
an optional published year and a set of
colors that you can choose from
now let's look at our request options
we have a general type that has a body
headers and query parameters all of them
are optional in the base
however we're defining the specific
shapes for each of the requests
for example our get requests have
an optional never body because they will
never contain a body
however our post input operations
have a required body of shape book
and also the update operation has an
optional e tag
that is passed into the headers the same
thing for the delete
so now let's fill them in the get
has an optional input
of type list
book options post
has a required one
of type create
book options put
also has a required input
update book options
here this will have also an optional one
input optional of tab get book
options and finally the delete also has
an optional input
with this we'll be able to help our
users to build their request payload
let's set the base book pad
and select the post method
we will be able to start building our
request if we create an empty object
and hit ctrl space we get the
suggestions for the properties that we
can pass
we see that the body is the required one
we select the body
and we start with another empty object
we see that the
that we get the required properties from
the book authors
caller id title and we can start
building up our request payload
thanks for joining me today i hope this
was helpful
here's a link to the code and my handle
on github
stay healthy and see you later